Don Kay leads a life that is considered
taboo in America by US law she is a he I
was born anatomically male I've lived
the majority of my life as a male Don is
not gay she's what's known as a
transsexual or transgendered person
someone who's born one sex but wants to
live the life of the other sex my old
name was Danny
and that's name I was born with as a
child little Danny was pressured to fit
into the usual gender role one christmas
burns in her memory well I was about
eight years old I was caught playing
Barbie dolls with my niece's I mean it's
kind of like one of those memories you
reflect back on the earliest time that I
was actually thinking in the role of a
female her parents swept in and snatched
away the doll after that Christmas Danny
grew up a model of manhood he finished
high school and joined the military
eventually Danny sought out a therapist
who gave a rare diagnosis only about one
person in 12,000 is transsexual
following urges he had felt since
childhood
Danny became dawn
determined to be accepted as a woman
dawn got breast implants and took female
hormones but many transsexuals find it
difficult to hide their original gender
they retain a male physique and many
live in constant fear of humiliation the
only solution
dawn believes is to remove her male
genitalia dawn heard about a doctor in
Thailand who specializes in sexual
reassignment surgery what used to be
known as a sex change operation along
with removing her male genitalia dr. Sam
Guan will craft a full feeling vagina
if successful dawn will be able to
experience female orgasm during sex
alright dr. San Juan removes Don's penis
but leaves the nerve that will allow her
to feel sexual pleasure he creates an
opening that will serve as the new
vagina later he'll cut out a portion of
Don's colon to act as the vaginal canal
almost immediately
dawn rouses two weeks after surgery
dawn will finally get a look at the new
her anything I should not do nothing you
can do everything for dawn this is a new
beginning her new gender is about more
than identity it's also about love what
I'm looking for is a solid sound
relationship with a heterosexual guy so
it is the end for me but it's the end
one part of my life and it's the
beginning of a new part it's a rebirth
for me
[Music]